[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en France 24
Bienvenidos a África siete días estos
son los titulares en túnez los migrantes
de África subsahariana siguen siendo
Víctimas de abusos racistas
extremadamente violentos muchos tratan
ahora de huir inscribiéndose en las
listas de regreso voluntario a sus
países o intentando llegar a Europa a
toda costa en Sudáfrica los cortes
diarios de Electricidad siguen
envenenando la vida de millones de
personas y ponen en peligro la economía
de la primera potencia Industrial del
continente los detalles en un momento
una tierra sin hombres a 300 kilómetros
de nairobi la capital de Kenia el pueblo
de humo ya está prohibido a los hombres
y se ha convertido en Un refugio para
las mujeres Víctimas de mutilación
genital matrimonio forzado o violación
abrimos esta edición en el norte de del
continente en túnez tras el discurso
violento del presidente Kaiser el pasado
21 de febrero contra la presencia de
migrantes subsaharianos y el aumento de
las extracciones contra las personas
negras por parte de la población como de
las autoridades cientos de migrantes
viven angustiados y tratan de huir del
país a toda Costa algunos han decidido
regresar a sus países de origen mientras
que otros intentan llegar a Europa con
consecuencias a veces trágicas
la tragedia se produjo frente a las
costas de la región de fax en el centro
oeste de túnez en dos días 14 migrantes
murieron ahogados tras el naufragio de
sus embarcaciones improvisadas estos
accidentes se produjeron en un momento
en que muchos migrantes subsaharianos
intentan abandonar este país del norte
de África cuya Costa está a menos de 150
kilómetros de La Isla italiana de la
pelusa desde que el presidente tunecino
caizayet comparó los migrantes con
hordas que habían llegado a túnez a
sembrar el caos y cambiar la composición
demográfica Nacional los subsaharianos
así como los tunecinos afrodescendientes
han sido Víctimas de un recrudecimiento
de la violencia racista centenares de
estos migrantes corrieron tras lo
ocurrido a sus embajadas para ser
repatriados los que no tienen esta
posibilidad intentan ahora cruzar a
Europa
Es cierto que en las últimas
semanas
vinieron atunes fue por la situación
económica y social que sufrían en su
país principal objetivo es cruzar a
Europa
durante un encuentro con el presidente
saiet trató de justificar sus
declaraciones
esta situación que afecta a los
africanos no puede ser interpretada por
las malas lenguas como lo han hecho en
los últimos días como racismo de qué
hablan están divagando
según cifras oficiales túnez cuenta con
más de 21,000 ciudadanos de países del
África subsahariana La mayoría de ellos
En situación irregular en febrero unos
días antes de las polémicas
declaraciones de saiet una veintena de
un ejército de escinas ya habían
lamentado el aumento de la incitación al
odio y el racismo en el país
según las ongs las políticas europeas de
externalización de fronteras han
contribuido durante años a transformar
Tunes en un actor clave de la vigilancia
de las rutas migratorias en el
Mediterráneo
y seguimos en túnez donde además de esta
crisis la situación política continúa
bajo constante tensión en este contexto
dos años después del cierre del
parlamento por parte del presidente
y de su disolución en marzo de 2022 el
órgano legislativo ha reabierto sus
puertas sin presencia de la prensa El
mandatario declaró que no será como el
de antes desde su demostración de poder
en 2021
dijo en repetidas ocasiones que quería
romper con los partidos políticos y con
el sistema semi parlamentario que había
prevalecido tras la caída de la
dictadura en 2011 por tanto el nuevo
parlamento resultado de unas
legislativas con una abstención de cerca
del 89%
reanuda sus funciones con muy poco
margen de maniobra
cambiamos de tema la empresa francesa
total energía está llevando a cabo un
polémico megaproyecto de oleoducto en
uganda y en tanzania varias ongs piden
la suspensión de este proyecto por
violaciones a los derechos humanos Y al
medio ambiente pero el tribunal de París
rechazó las demandas de estas
organizaciones
considerando que no respetaron los
procedimientos en el centro de la
disputa hay 2 mega instalaciones el
proyecto chilena de perforación
petrolera que se está construyendo en
uganda con un tercio de las
perforaciones del parque natural de las
cataratas murcison y el proyecto eacop
el óleoducto de petróleo crudo de África
Oriental Este óleoducto calentado
eléctricamente es el más largo del mundo
y atraviesa tanzania y sus zonas
protegidas
para los defensores de los derechos
humanos y del medio ambiente la empresa
total energía incumplido con su deber de
precaución instituido por una ley
francesa de 2017 que obliga a las
multinacionales a evitar los abusos
contra los derechos humanos y el medio
ambiente total Energy Todavía no se ha
pronunciado sobre el caso escuchemos la
reacción del director de una de las ongs
demandantes tras la decisión judicial a
favor de total energía
[Música]
el tribunal no examinó el fondo del
asunto En otras palabras no evaluó
Realmente si las pruebas presentadas por
las comunidades eran buenas o malas se
fijaron en los aspectos técnicos de
eructa desde
lo que intentamos ahora es recurrir la
decisión pero también seguir un
procedimiento más largo por supuesto
esperábamos que el tribunal nos diera la
razón porque se trata de personas que
están sufriendo son comunidades locales
que no tienen dinero que no tienen
capacidad para comprometerse a contratar
abogados durante mucho tiempo pero por
supuesto tenemos que buscar Atentamente
otra opción para garantizar que la gente
obtenga justicia
continuamos nuestro recorrido por la
actualidad africana y vamos a Sudáfrica
donde el presidente ciri la rama posa
realizó una tímida remodelación de su
gabinete en un intento de recuperar la
confianza de los sudafricanos hasta las
elecciones generales de 2024 pero el
mandatario no ha corrido muchos riesgos
y ha confirmado En sus puestos a los
pesos pesados de su administración para
bien gordan Por ejemplo sigue siendo el
ministro de las empresas públicas cuando
es con el proveedor Público de energía
se ha hundido dejando a millones de
personas sin electricidad una situación
que además de repercutir en la vida
cotidiana de los sudafricanos representa
un peligro para la economía del país
se ve obligada a cocer a la luz de las
velas
su negocio como el de muchas otras
costureras del municipio de Michaels
Plain en Ciudad del Cabo se ve amenazado
por los cortes de Electricidad cada vez
más habituales en Sudáfrica
tuve que renunciar a muchos de mis
clientes no podía aceptar mucho trabajo
así que solo aceptaba la mitad
Esta es la peor crisis energética que ha
vivido el país
los sudafricanos pasan hasta 10 horas
diarias a oscuras debido a las
deficiencias de scom la compañía
Nacional de Electricidad este año la
crisis podría reducir el crecimiento
económico en un
2%. las autoridades locales de todo el
país recurren ahora a proveedores
privados para ayudar a empresas y
hogares a hacer frente a la situación
ciudad del Cabo se ha fijado el objetivo
de reducir a la mitad los cortes de
Electricidad para 2026
no se puede desarrollar una economía sin
electricidad como ciudad no estaríamos
teniendo esta conversación si es con
funcionará si el monopolio Estatal
funcionara pero como muchos monopolios
estatales del mundo no funciona es muy
ineficiente no ha invertido
adecuadamente está sobrecargado es muy
muy corrupto
Ciudad del Cabo también evalúa cambiar
su política energética para permitir que
los hogares Y las empresas que produzcan
energía solar le vendan el excedente
pero solo las grandes empresas y los
residentes ricos podrán permitirse
instalar paneles solares
paneles solares Pero por desgracia como
pequeña empresa no ganamos mucho dinero
para instalar paneles solares y cosas
así
públicas que sufrió el saqueo
generalizado de los recursos del Estado
bajo la presidencia de Jacob suma hoy
carga con una deuda de casi 21.000
millones de dólares
en otras noticias del continente una
delegación del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU concluyó una visita de tres días
a República democrática del Congo y
pidió negociaciones para poner fin a la
violencia que en Sangrienta a las
regiones orientales del país
la parte este de República democrática
del Congo fronteriza entre otros con
Ruanda está asolada por la violencia
Desde que la milicia del m-23 retomó las
armas a finales de 2021 y se apoderó de
franjas enteras del territorio empujando
al exilio a decenas de miles de personas
el embajador francés ante la ONU Nicolás
que formaba parte de la delegación que
visitó República democrática del Congo
acusó formalmente aruanda de apoyar al
m-23
ya está claro que Ruanda apoya el m-23
también está claramente establecido que
incursiones del ejército ruandés en la
región de cubo Norte y que esto también
es inaceptable por lo tanto esto es uno
de los temas que hay que discutir hay
que ponerle fin
noruanda por su parte niega a apoyar al
m-23 y acusa a su vez a República
democrática del Congo de apoyar a la
milicia de las fuerzas democráticas para
la liberación de Ruanda un grupo armado
que defiende los intereses de los hutus
ruandeses refugiados en República
democrática del Congo y que se opone al
presidente ruandés
nos vamos ahora a Kenia a la aldea de
umocha un lugar exclusivo para las
mujeres Víctimas de violencia física y o
sexual en este lugar donde los hombres
no son bienvenidos las mujeres se
sienten seguras y sobre todo son libres
de actuar y pensar por sí mismas algo
todavía poco frecuente en un país que
sigue dominado por una cultura
patriarcal y donde las mujeres no
siempre encuentran su lugar
entre árboles espinosos y casas
cubiertas de estiércol el pueblo de
umoya se parece a cualquier otro de la
región de samburu en el noreste de Kenia
salvo por un detalle esencial la
ausencia total de hombres desde su
creación hace más de 30 años humo ya ha
servido de Refugio a mujeres de la
comunidad zamburu y de otros lugares que
huyen de la mutilación genital femenina
la violencia doméstica o el matrimonio
infantil
tiene 26 años madre de cuatro hijos
decidió abandonar a su marido
maltratador
de la aldea dice que su misión es
garantizar que las niñas no se obligadas
a casarse con hombres mayores
no hay necesidad de tener hijos sin un
plan las niñas deben educarse y elegir a
sus propias parejas no como en el pasado
cuando sus padres las cazaban con
hombres viejos o ricos las niñas deben
elegir a quien quieren
en Kenia como en la mayoría de los
países africanos la violencia de género
afecta desproporcionadamente a las
mujeres las estadísticas gubernamentales
indican que más del 40% ha sufrido
violencia física o sexual por parte de
sus parejas a lo largo de su vida además
en el país la prevalencia del matrimonio
infantil y la mutilación genital
femenina es de aproximadamente el 23 y
el 21% respectivamente
así cerramos esta edición de África
siete días Si desean hacer comentarios o
preguntas envíenlos en la cuenta de
Twitter que aparece en pantalla Mientras
tanto la actualidad internacional
continúa en France 24
[Música]